las calles de la capital libanesa se
convirtieron en un campo de batalla de
este jueves los hechos ocurrieron luego
de que el grupo hezbollah apoyado por el
movimiento chiita amal convocará una
manifestación que pedía la destitución
del juez a cargo de la investigación
sobre la explosión del puerto de beirut
en 2020
para hasan dueño de una tienda que quedó
destruida la violencia le recuerda a la
guerra civil que dividió a su país
durante 15 años
esta escena nos llevó de regreso a 1935
yo tenía diez once años y ahora la misma
escena se repite tengo imágenes en mi
cabeza de cuando era un niño lo vivimos
de nuevo testigos aseguraron que las
balas provenían de edificios y los
tejados de algunas casas el tiroteo dejó
varios muertos y decenas de heridos al
menos nueve personas fueron detenidas
y lo ocurrido será objeto de seguridad y
de seguimiento judicial yo por mi parte
del haré porque la investigación de ella
la verdad de lo sucedido para que los
responsables e instigadores rindan
cuentas como en cualquier investigación
incluida la del puerto que fue y seguirá
siendo una prioridad de mi trabajo y
compromiso con los libaneses
en marzo los manifestantes chiítas
reclamaban la destitución del juez para
evitar encargado de la investigación de
la explosión del puerto de beirut que
dejó al menos 200 muertos y 6.500
heridos acusan a evitar de
posicionamiento político ya que la
mayoría de los imputados acusados de
negligencia son cercanos al grupo
hezbollah y amal el magistrado estaba a
cargo de la investigación desde que su
predecesor fue destituido en febrero
evitar no ha logrado hasta ahora
interrogar a funcionarios de alto rango
así como ex ministros del gobierno por
ahora nadie ha sido acusado por la
mortal explosión